hey guys it's April 13 I'm chastity and
I'm back for more news but only for
today sorry anyway before we get into it
be sure to subscribe to our channel on
YouTube what do you already did that
right I'm still proud of you now let's
get into today's stories first up
intendo is discontinuing the NES classic
edition wait what no no I didn't get one
yet so after just six months on the
market Nintendo says it is discontinuing
the NES classic edition in North America
Nintendo did not provide a specific
reason for why the consoles being
discontinued but the plug and play
system has been plagued with supply
issues months after its launch it was
still selling out almost as quickly as
new shipments were released throughout
April anyway territories will receive
the last shipments of nes classic
edition systems for this year Nintendo
said in a statement we encourage anyone
interested in obtaining the system to
check with retail outlets regarding
availability we understand that it has
been difficult for many customers to
find a system and for that we apologize
we have paid close attention to consumer
feedback and we greatly appreciate the
incredible level of consumer interest
and support for this product Nintendo
has only said so far that nes classic
edition is being discontinued in North
America when asked whether the
discontinuation would be applied
globally a representative from Nintendo
said please see the statements made by
nintendo in other territories the nes
classic edition launched last november
coming preloaded with 30 classic nes
games next up Bandai Namco released a
teaser trailer for a mysterious new game
dark souls publisher Bandai Namco is
teasing a new project the company
released a trailer today to show off the
game those say for some interesting art
we have very few clues as to what the
title might be the video ends with the
tagline prepared to dine which could be
a reference to dark souls often use
prepare to die slogan an official
announcement is coming on April
twentieth Bandai Namco said in a press
release however any potential link is
unconfirmed and it's unclear whether
this cheese game is to be a new entry in
the Dark Soul series a spin-off or
something else altogether
and finally minecraft is coming to
nintendo switch next month nintendo
announced that microsoft's minecraft
will launch digitally for nintendo
switch on May eleventh with a physical
release coming at a later date nintendo
confirmed the news in its most recent
direct stream in which splatoon two and
arms also got release dates of july 21st
and june sixteenth respectively nintendo
also confirmed that the switch version
will support both online and local
multiplayer a players can play together
online while up to four can craft at
once on the TV in split screen or in
tabletop mode in addition minecraft
Super Mario mash-up pack will also come
to switch allowing you to explore blocky
versions of Mushroom Kingdom themed
worlds alongside characters such as
Luigi and waluigi tell tales
narrative-driven adaptation minecraft
story mode has also been confirmed for
the switch so we don't yet know when
that is you out they had me at waluigi
anyway that's all for me today but be
sure to hang out with me tomorrow for a
both storm full clip edition livestream
starting at 11am pacific time on our
youtube and twitch channels or on
gamespot com wherever you want to hang
out and we're also having a Star Wars
Celebration reaction livestream right
before that at 8am see you tomorrow